les décombres et d'expression c'est pour
ça que cette semaine on s'est fait le
top des lapsus à la télé alors on
démarre avec un gros problème de langage
on a une bafouille exceptionnelle d'un
politique belge philippe busquin le mec
sûr de lui continue sa phrase comme si
de rien était sa passe directe quand il
continue le garçon pour faut-il laisser
tout faire comme certains le disent dans
la pensée libérale pure et simple
non il faut accepter les changements et
nous les leaders socialistes européens
nous réunissons sur ce point il faut
activer des changements il dit pas un
mot plus bas prix
il savait mais on dis ces lapsus et
bafoue elle avait beaucoup de
vocabulaire et sap animateurs il ya deux
ans moi c'est bon quoi mais qu'est ce
qu'elle à la prof de français et emile
cohl toute l'équipe a donc usé moi avons
branché avec vous monsieur merci ses
lapsus et bassoues voilà c'est pas moi
si je savais que vous mettiez une
bafouille sais pas si la meuf est
complètement bourré ou si son cerveau se
déconnecte pendant quelques secondes
mais si l'un d'entre vous comprends ce
qu'elle a voulu nous dire sas une
bafouille vous allez voir est à l'aps
s'il y en a un qui comprend ce qu'elle
dit franchement oui je l'envoie en week
end avec la personne de son choix
et bien sûr avec la compagnie skyline
regardez quand on a des nouvelles tous
les jeux regarder à la fin même la femme
mlc fatigué tout seul regarde pour une
poubelle surtout parce que mon mari il
n'avait pas apporté tout sera ok allez
on veut c'est pas une bafouille vous
n'êtes peut-être vous n'êtes pas
observateurs d'un petit décrochement des
dentiers un petit point de rater la
remise à les voir des poubelles surtout
parce que mon mari qui est porteur tout
sera ouvert aux bunkers chaud allez on
va je construirais un bunker pour aller
on verra à l'abc c'est une belle chance
selon hadja lahbib la présentatrice une
question et suçaient plutôt que susciter
la question a souvent été gelées avant
dessus cessé de susciter de telles
conséquences adel lassouli revient sur
la saga bhv ses ennemis un lapsus d'une
bafouille c'est un orgasme
tiens à dire tint à la puce que tout le
monde baboo mois sur village départ avec
laurent luyat j'ai fait cinq tours de
france et amendé je faisais je
présentais une quatrième cycle est tous
bien et courait derrière nom et est
alors je présentais une cathédrale qui
avaient été élevés au culte de la vierge
marie et j'ai pas dit la vierge est dit
la verge marana were all alors là c'est
en direct de rigoler mais je comprenais
pas parce que je mets une oreillette
j'entendais place que j'avais la vierge
marie
c'est en tout cas ça devait être sympa
en direct la cie en direct du bar un
truc vraiment un délire c'est sûr il me
ferait penser à ne plus poser de
questions merci aux tab suce moi c'est
moi c'est moi j'en ai fait un don tpm
pas j'ai voulu présenter la nouvelle
star du foot
et voilà ce que ça a donné un air voilà
ensuite incombe et en canards bien sûr
il ya la nouvelle star du foot mario
dufour
non
en direct sur sa carrière c'est fait on
dirait qu'ils ont perturbé à la nouvelle
star du foot ça passe et s'attache à
joly quelqu'un non
les chiffres eux c'était en plein été 94
dans 40 degrés à l'ombre
j'appelais de cette émission c'est
vincent perrot appelle les
téléspectateurs à composer 36 à 1,3615 à
l'époque
neymar et donne le code pour départager
trois jeunes femmes sa part en énorme
fou rire regarder le lapsus la star
lapsus fédéraux mais alors vous avez
animé au téléphone 36,15 god fr3 la
première fois que j'entends s'était pas
fait ça faut qu'il s'entend très bien
avec julien lepers brasse patrice
laffont
voilà je vous le dis dans mes frais il a
ensuite entamé avec julien lepers tôt
pascal je le connais pas personnellement
donc la nuit oui parce que je te le dis
houle a proposé plusieurs personnalités
dont la semaine garder on va proposer à
l'ua le perse de donner son avis sur
plusieurs personnages avaient eu
d'embrouillé avec lui a jamais eu
d'embrouillé que les petits passent au
tas ça te les inconnus mais en tout cas
moi perso j'ai jamais dit pascal on
voulait pas le diffuser au début si tu
peux voir ce qu'il a dit toi tu le dis
si l'on peut ou non sa servante j'ai pas
souvenir mais parce que j'ai eu avec
toni n'a pas voulu creuser
non je pense que c'est avec les inconnus
mais donc c'est vrai mais a pris comme
là il fallait pas de bonjour pascal
légitimus sera notre invité la semaine
prochaine pascal légitimus
[ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sincèrement d'accord dont tu as fait une
semaine qu'on attend pourquoi j'aime
aussi j'attends du sommet social
sincèrement j'ai jamais d'ombg semaine à
croire que tu sois pas au courant parce
que il est quand même assez violent à
ton endroit est très revanchard que
l'insulté elle est forte quand même mais
ben qui m'appelle je sais pas cédric
franchement ramasse calais pascal est un
garçon charmant voulait qu'on l'appelle
jeu bien oui allez on l'appelle en
sincèrement on appelle julien lepers
vial encore mieux et en appelant ses
directs induits weppes ont été de loin l
anc hull et pourquoi seulement qu il est
donc un peu à l'eau ici l'enculé c'est
violent non mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas top alors masqué non c'est la
compagnie alors on va on va continuer et
puis on verra si on la halle et chérie
je crois que le mot buzz reste l'un des
lapsus était plus facile à la télé vous
verrez que maintenant depuis le buzz le
buzzer regardez ce moment benjamin
castaldi ont fait les frais sur le
plateau de secret story benjamin
castaldi qui avait des yeux grands
ouverts à l'époque
aujourd'hui neuf semaines leurs semaines
de mission neuf semaines de pression
neuf semaines de dissimulation mais
aussi neuf semaines de buzz
justement pas de buzz
[Applaudissements]
autre très beau lapsus qui vous l'avez
vécu pascal c'était sur le bateau de
merci encore bravo christine bravo
demande à anne roumanoff comme elle
combat le crack plutôt que le trac
regardez ça c'était magique au sérieux
ouais c'est vrai que pour combattre le
crack le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît dessine moi j'étais dans
cette émission c'est le 19 décembre 81
vous étiez en dessous la table c'est la
première émission de télé je vais parler
d'aller sur le roman photo et bars dans
toutes les missions en corse ya le temps
ouais mais c'est que le roman photo sauf
additionnel ouais traditionnel web à
regarder on a l'image déjà bon c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
fabien lecoeuvre bonsoir bonsoir vous
publiez un livre les années roman-photo
aux éditions verriez vous êtes un pur et
dur du roman photo
oui c'est à dire qu'on a essayé faut
savoir qu'au départ nous sommes deux sur
la démarche de se livrer on a donc bruno
taco de gérad et moi même on a essayé de
c'est difficile d'avoir fait aujourd'hui
avec des comics dans les visions ça n'a
pas l'air comme ça mais c'est compliqué
de faire un roman photo
c'est presque comme au cinéma il ya un
synopsis des dialogues le tout est
découpé en séquences il ya un tournage
dit à personne et de la famille c'est
épouvantable
ainsi j'espère qu'un jour où sera
invitée de la grandeur qx ha
j'espère autres lapsus exceptionnelle
avec un candidat sur le plateau de tout
le monde veut prendre sa place avec
nagui regardez après des bêtisiers
bêtisier bêtisier on j'en ai un peu
marre mais la rançon du succès c'est que
grâce à bouger la rançon du succès alors
appliqué c'est important de préciser je
n'y suis pour rien parce que j'ai pas en
suisse elle même
[Applaudissements]
c'est à minuit les fabuleux je fais tous
les fachos demi et qui veulent aller
c'est ce qu'est un loukoum logo
biologique à regarder c'est pas une
pâtisserie c'est un problème un gros
problème au tube mais ça a provoqué un
énorme fou rire sur le plateau des 12
coups de midi avec jean luc reichmann
regarde compagnon elle permis il a des
problèmes des yeux qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme un problème aux yeux si un loukoum
élingues loukoum chérie c'est pour ça il
faut lui enlever les loups qui mêle
[Rires]
c'est lui un genre et on l'envoie selon
lui créent pas dans le rail au luc et
c'est vrai que c'est beau c'est mieux
d'en rire autre gros lapsus aussi c'est
jérémy michalak sur le plateau d'on
n'demande qu'à en rire une candidate peu
convaincante a été rapidement arrêté par
le jury par un double buzz t'es pas
obligé de regarder ce congé vais
m'absenter un petit peu voilà allez
regarder un lapsus ça donne ça j'achète
raconté un truc je vous avais été
doublement baiser peut prendre coupé
il m'arrive un truc de fou moi et qui
arrivent et michalak a un jour je
cherchais le numéro de laurent wiki
parce que laurent ruquier
j'avais eu un petit problème et non mais
tu vas voir tu vas aimer j'avais un
petit problème avec laurent roux qui est
forcément quand j'ai un problème je
jouais l'on recherche la personne et
donc je voulais appeler laurent henry
qui est donc j'ai le numéro de jérémy
michalak et je lui envoie est ce que tu
peux me passer le numéro de lot et qui
est jérémy et et moins en moins sms
pensant qu'il avait envoyé alors ok non
il ya hanouna qui me fait chier pour
avoir co numéro un non très courtois est
ce que vous l'avez reçu voilà oui oui
oui on adore ça certains producteurs
m'appelle et il est appelé plein de gens
pour l'émission sauf que le mec qui est
mon numéro trop tôt il s'entend dire
[ __ ] faut que j'appelle faut que
j'appelle ce connard de bachir trouvé le
nom des bleus ici c'était julien lepers
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur bfm on apprend qu'à l'assemblée le
siège des non pas des députés mais autre
chose
regardez amendements socialistes pour
taxer rétroactivement les heures
supplémentaires qui sera normalement
débattu d'ailleurs cet après midi par
les députés les députés l'entrée en
matière donc et c'est ce qu'on va finir
par abandon de revenir sur la sphère le
père si on va finir par le lapsus plus
récent c'est edouard philippe premier
ministre qui nous a régalés selon lui la
france est une nation qui veut continuer
à regarder parce que la france est une
nation qui veut continuer à se soucier
de l'enjeu parce que la france est une
nation pardon qui veut continuer à
susciter des grands champions dans tous
les domaines les jeux olympiques d'hiver
loup encore des mondes on nous dit que
les amateurs de rugby dont parfois
l'esprit mal placé
cette bonne foi et